these tanks are providing security for a
newly established forward base camp in
the plainy area the camp was set up by a
task force of 25th Infantry Division
elements as part of Operation Paul
Revere here in pleiku province the
Cambodian border is only 40 kilometers
away tents and facilities of the camp
cover a large area helicopters arrived
for resupply loading at this forward
base which is called Camp Oasis these
films were made during the third week of
June the camp was established to block
the Vietcong and prevent them from
infiltrating into South Vietnam from
Cambodia during the rainy season
Campbell ASIS is protected by tanks
while the troops are out on sweeps a few
kilometers away at the mouth of the
eardrum Valley an artillery battery sets
up for a fire mission to help prepare a
new landing zone in the valley where
operation Paul Revere will continue some
clearing work is required at the battery
position a Search and Destroy operation
Paul Revere has been in progress since
10 May with his aiming circle the
battery commander guides the emplacement
of the guns artillery missions in the
central highlands of South Vietnam are
complicated by steep hills and deep
valleys the 105 howitzers are adjusted
according to directions while some of
the crew men prepare rounds of
ammunition when the guns are properly
unplaced the crews site their weapons
and the pieces are ready for loading
the battery commander gives the order
and firing commences the highly-skilled
artillery men work calmly and
efficiently firing and reloading salvo
after salvo is fired as the commander
receives his orders from the FDC as the
barrage continues the assault troops are
heading for the objective landing zone
soon after the preparatory fire is ended
the assault troops of the tropic
Lightning task force land at the LZ and
another sweep begins from the landing
zone the troopers start moving up the
ear drum valley in search of the
Vietcong since the operation began on
May 10th more than 400 BC have been
killed and 72 captured friendly
casualties remain life at the village of
tun beam one a short distance from the
forward base camp a civic action
programme also gets underway with
medical aid for the villagers particular
attention is given the very young many
of whom are suffering from malnutrition
packages of food are among the tools
employed by the medical team in helping
to combat the rundown condition of many
of the children a Civil Affairs Unit
gives out tools in nearby Thanh Binh to
village as part of a self health program
the men of the village are grateful for
these implements
afterwards clothing which have been
collected in Hawaii is distributed there
is almost a bargain-basement air of
excitement as the villagers crowd around
the vehicle to choose from a variety of
donated garments the village women like
ladies everywhere clamor happily over
the clothing bonanza the items like this
purple muumuu don't always fit their new
owners but everyone seems pleased a few
days later on June 21 the vietnamese
second corps Armed Forces heroes Day is
celebrated at Pleiku headquarters
Major General Stanley Larsen commander
Field Force one Viet Nam attend a
particular interest is the contingent of
Multan yard women volunteers and their
banner south vietnamese civilian groups
are also represented as well as
uniformed irregular defense groups
banners proclaiming friendship for the
americans are in evidence all around the
parade ground in the ceremonies which
take place the South Vietnamese Minister
of Defense Lieutenant General million
who Co Awards medals to several American
soldiers for acts of heroism during
Operation Paul Revere
for these men of an artillery battalion
in Tweed law Thursday June 2nd begins
like almost every other day following a
night of harrassing fire into the jungle
in support of the 101st airborne the 105
millimeter howitzers are cleaned until
they shine and made ready for the next
fire mission ammunition is replenished
and stacked for the action which
inevitably lies ahead when the request
for support arrives the artillery men
are ready and waiting
the mission is fired quickly and
accurately then back to the continuing
job of maintenance without which such a
performance would not be possible
beside a runway at the vung tau airfield
in Vietnam men from an air traffic
control company set up a portable ground
control approach tower TPN 18 a
manufacturer's technical representative
supervises the installation observed by
the noncommissioned officer in charge
the tower is equipped with a TPM eight
radar antenna which is utilized for
search and scan operations as well as to
determine altitudes and weather
condition it also includes an iff or
identification Friend or Foe antenna
used to determine the identity of
aircraft this transmits directional
radar signals in code to all aircraft a
transponder carried aboard friendly
aircraft decodes the signal and provides
proper identification in return the
scopes and electronic equipment required
for air traffic control operations are
housed in a portable van
powered by its own generator the entire
assembly can operate at any location
into which it can be airlifted providing
safe and efficient control of both
fixed-wing aircraft and helicopters
and a RC 122 radio has been installed in
this uh-1b helicopter this set a Naples
a division or brigade commander to have
instant communication with his units
during operation it was developed to
overcome transmission difficulties due
to terrain features and has been in use
for three years at the Benoit airfield
another installation is underway here an
airborne command post radio set the ASC
six is being mounted in a command and
control helicopter this unit consists of
three different types of radios for AM
and FM operation
field commanders use this system to
coordinate and control ground troops to
call for artillery fire or air strikes
and to control helicopters making
assault landing with the installation of
the set completed the uh-1d lifts off to
be put through an equipment and
communications check inside
battalion officers study a map of the
area to verify the terrain over which
they are flying and conduct voice checks
with their ground units in the area
at Kent Gayler tonfa nuit Vietnam a
celebration in honor of the 106th
anniversary of the US Army Signal Corps
is conducted by personnel of a signal
battalion commanding officer of the
battalion Lieutenant Colonel Charles R
Myer presents awards for distinguished
service to outstanding members after the
awards colonel Myer delivers a signal
corps anniversary message he recalls the
founding of the Corps in 1860 by major
Albert J Meyer who with a handful of men
and equipment consisting of signal flags
and torches laid the foundation for the
present organization today the Signal
Corps fils army communications needs
around the world the ceremonies in
Vietnam are symbolic of over a century
of military communications progress
on 25 May in 12 it Nam a Vietnamese war
orphans home is the scene of a civic
action project the exchange club in San
Pablo California on learning of the
needs of Vietnamese refugees and war
orphans collected funds to purchase
items such as clothing soap and candy
they presented their gifts through a US
officer into evoi in addition a u.s.
serviceman donated two hundred
much-needed washcloths for the children
presents are distributed to the 225
children of this orphanage operated by
the Catholic Church other tenants led
her home was the factor which sparked
this project also on this same day
presents are given to children of the
Buddhist orphanage located elsewhere in
to evolve
in Saigon on 19 June Prime Minister no
encou key appears at a celebration of
the Vietnamese Armed Forces Day US
ambassador Henry Cabot Lodge is among
those present here at the transom of Air
Base the ceremonies begin as the Prime
Minister troops the line with his chief
of staff
then a wreath is placed on a monument
honoring the war dead and after the
presentation of medals to Vietnamese
servicemen and appropriate speeches the
Armed Forces Day parade begins 3,000
troops are in the line of march
representing every branch of service
including the military schools the
occasion also marks the first
anniversary of the Prime Minister's
regime
members of the montón yard forces both
men and women passed and review their
unusual uniforms present a striking
contrast to the modern appearance of the
armor which follows close behind them as
the parade concludes the spectators turn
their eyes to the sky parachutist of the
arvin forces jump and land successfully
on target before the reviewing stand a
flyover by planes of the vietnamese air
force brings the colorful ceremonies to
a striking conclusion
and ammunition and cargo fear is being
built in the sava heath area of Thailand
seen here on 21 June the pier is
approaching completion the facility is
designed to connect a tank farm directly
to seagoing tankers the tankers will tie
up alongside and the fuel will be pumped
directly into the pipeline it will
travel through the pipe for
approximately four kilometres to the
recently constructed pol tank farm all
pipeline construction is being done by
elements of the US Army engineers with
two platoons of a pipeline company
participating modern construction
machinery is provided for the work the
NCO in charge directs the pipeline crew
in the critical job of placing the pipe
sections an essential part of the set up
is the pumping station centrifugal pumps
send the fuel through the pipe a gate
valve is installed by the crew
the tank farm is 95% complete a
substantial quantity of vital fuel will
be stored here then trucked as needed to
a nearby u.s. airfield now under
construction
this floating bridge built by US Army
engineers in Santo Domingo will be
maintained by Dominican forces in the
near future personnel from fort benning
instruct a cadre of local dominican army
engineers in maintenance methods for the
floating facility a dominican officer
takes over the class in order to keep
the bridge in good condition members of
the cadre are trained in the Assembly of
the units and the equipment necessary
for their installation
planten's like those which make up the
existing bridge are hauled into the
water and floated in preparation for
assembly into a practice section of
bridge the pontoons are moved to the
assembly area by a powerboat under the
watchful eye of us instructors the
sections are joined running the
powerboat is an important part of the
instruction individual components of the
floating bridge may have to be repaired
or replaced occasionally and thorough
orientation in these procedures is
provided by the American engineers the
Dominican engineering cadre learn the
fundamentals and will train the rest of
their Battaglia when the exercise is
over the US Army Supervisors discuss
bridge construction methods with the
local team it's all part of the
inter-american mission in the Dominican
Republic
on 30 May the chief of staff of the
United States Army General Harold K
Johnson flies to Valley Forge
Pennsylvania to address a Memorial Day
assembly he speaks on the patriotic
traditions of America and over Armed
Forces among the highlights of his
speech are these words I would like to
speak for just a moment for something
that you may not be fully aware of and
that the way that our people and our
military services are performing today
and the reason that I want to talk about
this just briefly is because there has
been so much exposure of the dissidents
so much advertising of the protestors
that it seems to me that you would be
interested and proud to know that we
have more than three million Americans
in the uniform of their country who are
serving their country today in the
grandest tradition of the country it
took 26 years to forge our own nation
and when you look around the world today
at some of the nation's that are
struggling to establish themselves its
well to look back at our own to see the
difficulties that we have and I would
refer specifically to Vietnam 12 years
they've been struggling not quite half
the time that we've spent thirty six
thousand casualties they've taken since
1961 casualties at one and one-half
times the rate that we took them in
World War two so if you think the
Vietnamese aren't fighting change you're
thinking they are hard and they've been
fighting for a long time and they've
been fighting brave and they've been
dying brazen
and then something more than three years
ago the army was blessed with the young
captain who had almost omniscient and he
wrote back to his wife not very far from
here in New Jersey he wrote a series of
letters but he had just the treasure in
this statement when he said we must
stand strong and unafraid and give heart
to an embattled and confused people this
cannot be done if America loses heart
please don't let them back where you are
sell me down the river with talk of
despair and defeat talk instead of
steadfast and loyal and a fix or we must
and we can win here there is no backing
out of Vietnam or it will follow us
everywhere we go we must obey his
injunction stand strong and unafraid as
the nation and as individuals within
that nation it is hard to see how any of
us can do any less thank you